wir haben ja einmal 20 meter sei für
jeden hier finden sich heute heraus wer
die besseren noten machen kann
beziehungsweise werden zwei stunden die
besseren noten lernen wir werden jeweils
zwei stunden und quoten beizubringen
recherchieren und die beste strategie zu
überlegen weil wenn ich mich im
anschluss nur zehn minuten zeit haben
werden um einen fetten monster von
sebastian wäre dann gewonnen
anschließend wird die haben uns verboten
dann demgegenüber gegeben und man muss
man quasi mein kürten lösen
seit vier folgen treten marius
angeschrieben und ich jetzt schon
gegeneinander an
wir haben abwechselnd auf seinem und auf
meinem kanal kettenreaktion gebaut
würfel gestapelt gefährlich lange die
luft angehalten und ich habe mich ganz
schön aufs maul gelegt trotzdem steht es
aktuell zwei zu eins für mich heute
entscheidet sich also ob ich meinen
vorsprung ausbauen kann und in der
nächsten folge vielleicht den sieg wurde
oder ob marius nachzieht
das große problem zu kriegen
was soll ich damit 20 meter sei hat sich
das hinaus gedacht es ist ein atom us
gericht beschäftigen hier erstmal mit
einschlägiger fachliteratur anja könig
der knoten an das ist schon mal
vielversprechend der palast eckball
stieg fast unlösbar
erstmals nahm tutorial suchen ich suche
einfach angst so geht das versuche ich
jetzt mal dass die kölner sollte maximal
gelegen und komischen secret knoten
findet und wieder irgendeine komplett
kommen die strategie dann dringt wie zum
beispiel da wo einfach neu erfunden hat
wie man atmet
ich bin jetzt schon los das ja so ein
crazy gebilde was ich hier bei rott
gefolgt das kann jetzt einfach zusammen
zu judas
das steht so der geht nie wieder auf der
cloud das ist wohl das game video
gewesen die also wenn ich das ding hier
machen du willst du das aufmachen
ich will dass ihr okay weil hierdurch
hierdurch ja nee nee stimmt dann geht
das hier unten das ist ja auch eine ganz
schlimme bondage kunden
ich habe so eine szene vom knoten leuten
gefunden machen komplett gestört ich war
dass sie krank aus dass die yamaha what
the [ __ ] was ist das jetzt mal was die
da machen
hast du das zeug ich weiß dass ich jetzt
mal ich mach den ball aus knoten hier
vielleicht noch mal durch
[Musik]
okay ich bin gespannt was thomas hat zu
sagt erzeugen wir her du ja oder riesig
gemacht
also ich hab ja auch versucht den ball
zu du hast auch versuchen wir als wir
beim ersten bei mir erkennt man noch
nicht mal das ist also der monkey für
das heißt kann das heißt dass der
knochen ist aber durch die monkeys ist
aber auch affen faust genannt die marius
und ich hier knoten zeigt gut wie
vielseitig meinte knoten sein können
dieser knoten stammt nämlich eigentlich
aus der seefahrt wo er benutzt wurde um
würflein zu beschweren
viel erstaunlicher ist aber dass die
affen faust auch als waffe eingesetzt
werden kann quasi als mini morgenstern
in deutschland ist es sogar verboten
einen dieser knoten zu besitzen wenn das
innere zum beispiel mit einer kleinen
metallkugel beschwert wurde dann gilt
die affen faust nämlich als schlagwaffe
und auch in der seefahrt ist sie
inzwischen nicht mehr erlaubt weil es
beim werfen immer wieder zu verletzungen
kam
viermal den noch einmal versuchen meinen
eigenen jetzt aufzugeben 21
ich weiß noch gar nicht wo ich anfangen
soll dabei ausgeschlossen einfach
konnten wieder aufzulösen und ecken
schon auf seine frau dass wir 200
pädagogen am ende knapp unter eine
minute gebraucht das gleich jetzt wird's
ernst jeder von uns hat noch eine stunde
und 30 minuten zeit sich vorzubereiten
und seine finale strategie zu entwickeln
wäre dann länger braucht um den knoten
des anderen zu öffnen hat verloren bis
dahin muss also jeder handgriff sitzen
weitergeht ich würde sagen ich bin
erstmal ein deutlich längeres sei die
kunst wird es jetzt sein ein knoten zu
machen jetzt möglichst krass aber
trotzdem den mann noch innerhalb von
zehn minuten schafft weil über zehn
minuten in dem beschluss und wenn du
dann eigentlich hätten knoten anfangs
aber noch nicht genug thaler dass der in
herrlich zu ziehen dann ist er ganz zu
öffnen
voller körpereinsatz kann forschen dass
man war meine wade vielleicht so thomas
kling artikels ist dass am schluss noch
ab oder muss man an seinem bein löst
sehr gute frage
ja das wird dann vielleicht auch noch
eine herausforderung das teil
abzukriegen die sache ist halt so
vertraut sind und nicht ich will was
anderes machen ich glaube der shit ist
er wie so eine kordel sonne kordel des
todes zu machen das in der theorie
funktioniert das ich möchte es nur viel
länger machen gut dann will ich mal
sagen nicht nur vier am längen und er so
wild los geht's
okay wir noch 40 minuten zeit ich mal
sagen das ist auf jeden fall schon weit
nach unten aus wir wissen jetzt dass
spieler noch zu dem ball machen
ich versuche jetzt mal abzunehmen aber
das geht auf jeden fall ist sie nicht
auszusagen schienbeinschoner für arme
wenn ich mal als unfaires machen und das
ding einfach mal renditen ich kann halt
nicht jetzt hier einfach diese enten
anziehen weil sonst verspüre ich mir
direkt diesen sie sind eingang können
ist ein problem werden das ding
überhaupt auch nur fest zu schnüren
ich muss mir was anderes überlegen ich
ja heute möchte ich euch einmal den
sogenannten snk nord also den schlangen
knoten zeigen also ich will nicht sagen
aber der sehen wir sind ausländer
okay das ist ja recht straight forward
und ich glaube das kann man halt auch
türkisch mit 21 meter sei machen
ich glaube wenn man diese ganzen knoten
aufmachen muss ist schon stress
rückläufig abgestellte gewechselt ich
werde einfach versuchen möglichst viele
kleine knoten miteinander zu verbinden
und als aber möglichst rändern und
festzumachen ich hätte es mal wie lange
ich brauche um den hier zu öffnen und co
[Musik]
vier minuten fast gleichzeitig ist
einfach nur ein entgegenkommen weil wir
überlegen was mit der taktik machen
kannst du okay aber so viel sei ich weiß
ja dass man das wird eher so ein stress
mit diesem sei das ist schlimmer als
alle kabel kopfhörer der welt zusammen
jetzt hat sich von selbst verheddert
kann so ein flashback im schnitt nicht
so gemacht habe einmal müssen wir das
wird so spritzt heute wo ist das denn
überhaupt schule hin zu vielseitig
weiszumachen 321 schluss schluss alles
klar ist dass ganzen sagen ich habe so
viel also gehen wir jetzt ein bisschen
mehr glaubst du wer ich habe auch zur
folge sagt wäre das ganze sein und ist
nur los also ich hab halt andere gemacht
und habe stunden lang gebraucht um das
war zu viel soll ich weiß dass es nicht
einfach ist wie es am anfang war oh mein
gott wie so lustig heiße ich habe
komplett vergessen das ging ja eher
sowas wie wichtig ein toller mix gemacht
als ich diesen ersten schlangen knoten
nein das muss hier nicht um einen gott
ist das vorbei
nicht vergessen wieder ein komplettes
black alt als meine strategie ist auch
extrem ausgaben man das sagen das ganze
am anfang war jetzt
der erste knoten die waren sind nachts
nach drei minuten
props alter vor der kurzen stress meines
lebens alter von außen den dreifach
verzichten häcksler gemacht
es ist also klar
321 stock sieht ja aus wie sein
richtiger schmerz und bäcker das ist
einmal das event erstklässer so sind
hier gibt's auch krebs ist jetzt wird
halt aber erst richtig spannend weil das
sagt er sagt gar nichts und wer schnell
ist kriegt ersten punkt und depressiv an
das ist einmal im regen das ist nervig
geht er denn hin und alle die schnell
machst du das dem artefakt gerade ist
einfach am abgehen dann maximal wirklich
was wir gemacht haben weil du hast aber
auch so richtige kleine bis knoten
gemacht und sehe ich aus als hätte ich
glaub mir so eine technik kann ich ziehe
mir um mein gott ist schon fertig doch
gewusst dass verliere ja ziemlich
komplett trawler von ok ich habe jetzt
gefunden dass ich nur einige von diesen
fäden herausziehen muss man bricht das
ganze ding ist sozusagen als amtlicher
braucht das findest du ja neu ist es
jedes mal denke ich als erzielt jetzt
komplett leer
das ist glaube ich der letzte der das
ist das auch mein gott artur matt barnes
kv 314 zu wissen was das heißt
matchpucks verpasst ich uns dass wir
morgen gewinnen sondern dritte staffel
gewann
ob marius noch ausbauen kann oder ob ich
die staffel gewinnen ihr seht ihr im
nächsten video bei markus offen knallt
link ist eine video beschreibung auch in
der video beschreibung ist ein link zu
meinem schnittkurs stehen hier innerhalb
von kürzester zeit alles lernen was sie
für youtube videos musik videos und
urlaubsvideos braucht er ist wir kommen
wieder der einsteiger und
fortgeschrittene geeignet ist halt
einmal und können solche oft angenommen
und so oft wiederholen wie ihr möchtet
oder wie es braucht nur für die nächsten
drei tage gibt es zum ersten mal seit
monaten wieder rabatt und zwar 30
prozent mit dem connery link dazu ist
der video beschreibung und wenn ihr mich
jetzt auf dieser reise begleiten möchte
dann abonniert gern diesen kanal oder
[Musik]